bonjour à tous bienvenue à strasbourg
nous sommes ensemble pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne
dans cette émission je vous emmène dans
le tarn sur les lieux du très
controversé projet de barrage de sivens
sur la zone humide du testait souvenez
vous en octobre dernier rémy ferait s'il
trouvait la mort tué par un tir de
grenade depuis bruxelles a lancé une
procédure d'infraction contre la france
pour non respect de la directive cadre
sur l'eau et le projet est en suspens
mais pro et anti continue encore de s'y
affronter chaque jour mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est le retour du type de
taffetas du gmt le grand méchant marché
transatlantique
un dernier round de négociations a eu
lieu à bruxelles la semaine dernière et
comme d'habitude rien n'a filtré
alimentant une fois de plus les rumeurs
et les inquiétudes alors taffetas le
type at il du plomb dans l aile
c'est la question la semaine et elle est
posée par simon barbarie
on les avait presque oublié et pourtant
les négociations autour du ttp ont
repris à bruxelles il ya quelques jours
mais si rappelez-vous le tti p le
partenariat transatlantique sur le
commerce et l'investissement
cet accord qui mettra en place une
gigantesque zone de libre échange entre
les états unis et l'europe un marché de
820 millions de consommateurs soit un
tiers des plus commerciaux de la planète
depuis juin 2013 la commission
européenne a reçu l'autorisation des
états membres pour négocier en leur nom
avec les états unis
mais voilà en 2015 alors qu'on entame le
huitième round de ces pourparlers le
climat est de plus en plus hostiles au
tt ip en europe à commencer par le
nouveau gouvernement grec le parti au
pouvoir syriza a déjà annoncé qu'il
ferait valoir son droit de veto et oui
une fois le pack négociée devra être
soumis au vote unanime des 28
gouvernement de l'union européenne
mais il devra aussi être ratifié par le
parlement européen puis par les
parlements nationaux
en france ce sont les sénateurs qui
viennent de voter une proposition de
résolution européenne contre les fds des
tribunaux privé qui devront trancher en
cas de différend entre une entreprise et
un état et par là la possibilité de
condamner un état si jamais sa
législation fait perdre de l'argent à
une multinationale des états sont ainsi
menacés de sanctions financières
massives pour des décisions d'ordre
sanitaire sociale ou environnementale
cette pression exercée sur eux risquent
de les décide de les dissuader de
légiférer et les citoyens européens dans
tout ça eh bien ils sont 145 1000 sur
cent cinquante mille à avoir dit non au
tt ip dans un questionnaire en ligne de
la commission européenne alors l'accord
de libre échange at il du plomb dans l
aile
gmt taffetas pts et rip voilà les noms
avec lesquels on désigne en fait cet
accord de libre échange qui est en cours
de négociation avec les états unis
l'accord avec le canada par exemple
l'industrie plus de cinq ans il n'est
toujours pas entérinée
et pour évoquer cette question c'est
emmanuel maurel que je reçois bouger
d'être avec nous quand vous voyez un
petit peu ça est ce que vous vous dites
que finalement toute la campagne qui a
lu pendant les élections européennes sur
le gmt donc le grand marché
transatlantique anti taffetas anti tti
paix s que on n'est pas en train de tuer
dans l'oeuf quelque chose qui est même
pas complètement négocier c'est pas
qu'on tue dans l'oeuf mais en effet pour
la campagne des européennes
c'était un des sujets qui étaient le
plus abordé par les électeurs alors même
qu'on a parfois l'impression que les
gens s'intéressent pas ce type de deux
problématiques et nous interpellait
parce qu'ils avaient peur vous avez peur
en disant est ce que ça va avoir des
conséquences sur mon alimentation par
les amants chlorés bien sûr c'est ce que
ça va avoir des conséquences pour les
services publics
est-ce que ça va avoir des conséquences
pour mon emploi en tant que salariés et
ces questions elles sont légitimes parce
que on nous dit enfin la commission nous
a longtemps dit si on signe cet accord
la croissance va exploser ses intentions
selon les ménages vont gagner en pouvoir
d'achat sauf qu'on n'en sais rien parce
qu'il ya des études qui disent
exactement le contraire
et puis il ya des inquiétudes légitimes
sur les normes sociales sur les normes
environnementales
c'est normal que les gens se posent la
question est en effet il ya eu un
questionnaire la commission était très
discrète qui demandait l'avis des
citoyens sur le recours à des tribunaux
privé pour arbitrer des différends entre
les états et les investisseurs et 97 %
des gens ont répondu non on veut pas de
ça parce qu'on estime que les états unis
comme l'europe ont des tribunaux
aujourd'hui ordinaires qui sont
suffisamment aguerrie pour régler ce
genre de problème donc vous voyez
aujourd'hui on est au milieu du gué mais
moi je crois quand même que il ya plus
de questions et plus de risques que
davantage c'est pour ça que ça fait pour
vous on arrête tout on ne négocie pas on
arrête là on je vous parlais de l'accord
de change aussi avec le canada qui n'est
toujours pas en fait un terrible
inventif il n'est pas ratifiée ici par
le parlement européen
qu'est ce qu'on attend il a eu cinq ans
de négociations est ce que c'est du
boulot pour rien est ce qu'on tire la
chasse et on met à la poubelle
ça sent s'est jamais du boulot pour rien
mais en même temps il faut quand même se
poser les questions au fond parce que au
delà des débats sur la transparence
c'est vrai que tout ça est quand même
négocier c'est vrai condensé total au
passé exactement
au-delà des questions sur la
transparence la vraie question qui se
pose c'est est-ce que c'est nécessaire
parce que il ya déjà des relations
commerciales avec le canada ou avec les
états unis des droits de douane a baissé
notamment évidemment est depuis
longtemps la question c'est est-ce que
c'est nécessaire d'aller plus loin
est ce que vraiment on doit avoir des
accords privilégiés avec des pays comme
le canada ou les états unis qui ont les
grosses entreprises des multinationales
contre les intérêts financiers bien
compris mais qui ne fonctionne pas
forcément comme les entreprises
européennes qui n'ont pas les mêmes
normes qui n'ont pas le même droit du
travail qui n'ont pas les mêmes dans ce
cas là est ce qu'il serait pas temps vu
que vous avez des puissances émergentes
type en chine et c'est de mettre en
place au niveau du monde occidental
alors après on est d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord sur le principe
et bah des règles communes qui nous
permettent à un moment de mettre en
place des normes qui soit pas celle de
lestang ça justement c'est l'objet de
négociations dans le cadre de l'om c'est
ce qu'on appelle le multilatéralisme
sauf que le multilatéralisme en ce
moment ça a du plomb dans l aile
donc la commission a dit bamba dans ce
cas là on va faire des négociations
bilatérales
la diva canada mais la difficulté c'est
que nous ce qu'on souhaiterait c'est une
harmonisation par le canot les états
unis n'est pas forcément le cas des
états unis reprenons la question du
droit du travail par exemple
vous savez que les états unis n'ont pas
ratifié certaines normes de l'oit et
l'organisation internationale du travail
légitimement les syndicats de salariés
en europe et notamment en france et 10
ma tension si moi je me retrouve dans un
accord avec des salariés américains qui
ne sont qui n'ont pas les mêmes règles
j'ai des craintes pour ma protection
j'ai des craintes pour les règles qui
régissent ma vie au travail en clamant
des inquiétudes un gîte quoi je sais pas
s'il faut arrêter mais en tout cas je
pense qu'il faut prendre le temps de la
réflexion notamment sur le bien fondé de
cet accord est ce que vraiment il ya
plein d'études qui sortent en ce moment
il ya un risque pour une pression à la
baisse sur les salaires en europe de
destruction de sens surtout il ya un
risque c'est ce que démontre un certain
nombre d'économistes à ce que les flux
transatlantique de commerce se substitue
au commerce intra-européen est ce que
c'est ce qu'on veut et ce c'est notre
intérêt
moi je ne crois pas donc en tout cas je
sais pas s'il faut arrêter mais il
serait temps de prendre le temps la
difficulté c'est que la commission et
même la présidence layton a dit faut
qu'on aille le plus vite possible
pourquoi parce que il ya cette religion
du libre échange ils partent du principe
que le libre échange c'est bien et que
forcément ça va apporter de la
croissance
moi je n'y crois pas je pense qu'il faut
prendre le temps de la réflexion cecilia
malmstrom inquiets comme carey qui est
chargé de négocier cet accord français
sa direction qui est chargé de négocier
cet accord vous diriez qu'elle n'est pas
à la hauteur de l'exercice elle est très
libérale mais elle justement moi je
l'interrogé alors c'est quelqu'un de
très intelligent et de compétent mais ça
fait partie ne remet même pas elle se
remet jamais en question notamment sur
ces mesures sur le libre échange c'est
bien elle dit c'est bien on lui demande
pourquoi c'est bien c'est comme ça c'est
pas très laïque qu il ya une sorte de
religion du libre échange et du marché
mais on n'est pas surpris ici à
strasbourg parce que c'est le cas de
beaucoup de commissaires et de certains
députés notamment de droite l'idée que
toute façon le marché règle tout et nous
allons vers le meilleur des mondes
possibles
en attendant le monde c'est pas le
meilleur possible et moi je pense qu'au
contraire faut des règles des normes
faut des lois donc cesser le débat avec
madame maelström et avec d'autres alors
justement il y en a un qui essaye depuis
quelques jours de remettre un petit peu
ces règles en question ses allées ces
petits princes qui a pris la tête de la
grèce il ya quelques semaines et enfin
quelques jours même il a fini sa tournée
européenne et en a profité donc dimanche
de retour au parlement pour faire son
discours de politique générale et il y
en a une qui a été taclé c'est madame
merkel et l'allemagne je vois qu'on
écoute
pères à breslau cymbales à l'eps hors
jeu ne peut écarter une obligation
morale une obligation morale non
seulement envers notre peuple une
obligation morale envers l'histoire
envers tous les peuples d'europe qui ont
combattu et de donner leur sang contre
le fascisme l'obligation historique d'un
nouveau gouvernement de réclamer le prêt
d'occupation et les réparations auto iv
emmanuel maurel est ce qu'il faut que
l'allemagne rembourse ses dettes de
guerre est ce que c'est un peu
passéistes comme manière de forme et
surtout je crois que type race ils
utilisent et il a raison la provocation
pour susciter l'intérêt et pour susciter
le débat
est-ce que c'est pas contre-productif à
ce que sa va pas plutôt suscité non je
ma peur et la suspicion mais mentalement
non non je crois que mais il ya un
rapport de force avec madame merkel ça
c'est sûr et si prince l'assumer de ce
point de vue là pour nous une bonne
nouvelle parce qu'on le dit pas assez
moi j'essaie de convaincre mais mes
collègues sociaux démocrates
mais ce rapport vous faites parti de
gauche dit oui je fais partie du groupe
social-démocrate et je suis plutôt à
gauche ça c'est sûr en tout cas je suis
résolument de gauche mais ce qui est
intéressant dans ce que fait si prince
et dans ce qu'il dit c'est que ça donne
un point d'appui formidable à tous
celles et tous ceux qui veulent
réorienter la construction européenne et
moi de ce point de vue là j'ai trouvé
que c'est une formidable nouvelle
après
vous sentez bien de toute façon que la
plupart y compris de mes collègues se
dit çà peut pas continuer comme ça
l'austérité ça donne une catastrophe
sociale dans la plupart des pays la
course au moins disant social ça
inquiète les populations
et puis surtout on a quand même un enjeu
politique fort c'est qu'il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui se détournent du projet
européen va regarder l'hémicycle de
strasbourg
oui il y en a 150 cd nationaliste et
xénophobe est ce qu'on peut continuer
comme ça non donc forcément il faut
réorienter la consoler avec tous ses
proches y contribuer on nous avait dit
ça en 2012 lors de l'accession au
pouvoir de françois hollande on va
réorienter l'europe
on va aller vers la croissance on nous a
redit la même chose avec l'arrivée au
pouvoir de matteo renzi en italie idem
aujourd'hui avec type race en grèce à
chaque fois on a eu des rendez vous
manqués alors à quoi bon encore se dire
que vous êtes en capacité intéressante
et le rang j'espère qu'on peut
réorienter l'europe parce que si vous
savez l'europe elle peut mourir oui elle
est d'à côté on a vu avec hollande que
ça va fonctionner avec matteo renzi
colombie il a fait une faute à mon avis
est qu'il n'a pas renégocier le tcg
l'arrivée de renzi a quand même un peu
changer les choses parce que justement
il ya eu un axe renzi hollande
et vous avez vu que même la commission
s'est pourtant des gens assez peu
inventif
on dit bon bar va c'est faire un plan
d'investissement alors le plan juncker
il est insuffisant c'est un peu de la
poudre aux yeux sur certains points mais
quand même il ya cette prise de
conscience que si on relance par
l'investissement public et privé en
europe on va dans le mur
la décision de draghi la bce il ya deux
semaines pour assouplir un peu la
politique monétaire sa y participent
aussi
donc il ya des choses qui bougent mais
le problème de l'europe c'est que c'est
un énorme paquebot pour le faire bouger
la faute du temps
la victoire de sipera c'est une nouvelle
étape dans cette volonté de réorienter
la construction européenne donc de ce
point de vue là c'est positif
alors je voudrais qu'on parle un petit
peu rapidement de la question française
là là dedans on voit bien que ce syriza
qui a fait office d'alternative en grèce
podemos en espagne qui est le parti qui
est sorti du mouvement des indignés en
irlande ya un parti anti austérité qui
se met en place
pourquoi en france on n'est pas capable
de transformer l'essai pourquoi est ce
que la gauche de la gauche n'est pas en
capacité de capitaliser pourquoi est-ce
qu'on france l'alternative c'est le
front national
d'abord il ya des raisons historiques
pourquoi je dis ça c'est parce que en
grèce par exemple ils ont eu le régime
des colonels donc la dictature d'extrême
droite ces récents et savent ce que
c'est en espagne ils ont connu le régime
franquiste donc l'extrême droite ils
savent ce que c'est nous pour notre
bonheur d'une certaine façon
depuis 1945 on n'a pas connu ce type
d'expérience donc voilà après c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le front national même si
je suis quand on regarde son programme
ce n'est absolument pas le cas essaye de
passer pour être une alternative anti
austérité
quand on regarde le programme de madame
le pen s'est évidemment pas le cas où
son analyse de l'extrême gauche sur
certaines sommes pas du tout le pas du
tout soit dit on l'a vu à la gare au
vote expliqué que tout le malheur du
monde notre pays vient d'une immigration
massive mais sur la question de
l'austérité il ya quand même des
discours qui se sont croisés mais sauf
qu'il ya un discours après les
préconisations
c'est il faut sortir leur en faut sortir
de l'euro évidemment ce n'est pas à mon
avis c'est parce que nous devons
souhaiter
et c'est parce que la gauche souhaite
mais moi ce que j'aimerais et au parti
socialiste un débat en ce moment c'est
que justement on se reconnaissent dans
ce refus de l'austérité et qu'on se
reconnaissent aussi c'est ça l'intérêt
de podemos et le syriza dans celles et
ceux qui proposent des solutions
alternatives parce que y'en a
contrairement à ce qu'on nous dit
si vous là il ya des alternatives ya pas
une seule politique possible si avec une
seule politique possible ce serait
désespérant
en démocratie des milliers de choix
possible et moi j'aimerais que la gauche
emprunter une autre voie que celle
qu'elle est en train d aujourd'hui
d'emprunter hélas merci beaucoup
emmanuel maurel d'avoir avec nous on
reparlera des alternatives nous on
continue sur ces gens qui souhaitent
fonctionner autrement le 1er février
dernier a eu lieu la journée des zones
humides une occasion pour nous de
revenir sur le dossier du barrage de
sivens souvenez vous en octobre dernier
rémy fraysse avait été tué par un tir de
grenade depuis bruxelles a lancé une
procédure d'infraction contre la france
pour non respect de la directive cadre
sur l'eau et le projet est en suspens
mais pro et anti continue encore de
s'affronter chaque jour sur place c'est
un reportage de sandra cerqueira
c'est ici qu'est mort rémy fraysse tué
par une grenade lors d'une manifestation
à l'endroit où les travaux de
déboisement ont commencé en septembre
dernier sur le site du très contesté
projet de barrage de sivens dans le tarn
ça c'est une marie kaddes
parce que là ils ont même causé un peu
dans le pont couanau le cas c'est moi
j'aurais dit non qu'il faut pas trois
semaines de travaux détruisent une
partie de la zone humide du tester l'une
des plus importantes de la région
donc ici là il ya une dalle qui a été
dressé en argile compact et je ne sais
pas comment elle fait d'épaisseur mais
elle est assez épaisse donc pour le
moment cette zone là empêche les
écoulements les écoulements souterrains
et de nourrir la zone humide que l'on a
en aval
quand elle a commencé à couper tout au
bord la les bois mais déjà le milieu
était très perturbée quoi donc ici à cet
état il est perturbé mais il peut
repartir
d'ailleurs nous on travaille déjà sur la
réhabilitation de la zone
il y en a qui disent dans le 50 ans elle
sera co aval c'est pas vrai c'est ce que
reproche bruxelles à la france en
novembre dernier
harry reçoit une procédure d'infraction
pour atteinte à la directive sur l'eau
datant de 2000 avec une digue de plus de
300 mètres de long et 12 mètres de haut
le projet de barrage mettrait en péril
le site qui abrite de nombreuses espèces
protégées
la commission européenne a critiqué la
france sur le fait que le barrage aller
rompre la continuité écologique barret
le cours d'eau donc empêché la migration
déserte à poissons depuis les travaux
sont gelés et les lieux occupés les à
dist refuse d'être filmé tous dénoncent
un projet illégal passer en force par le
conseil général du tarn
ce qui est vraiment scandaleux c'est que
quand le chantier a démarré début
septembre quand ils ont commencé à
déboiser à défricher l'état le conseil
général savait déjà que la commission
européenne refusait la réponse de la
france donc il savait déjà que le projet
serait recalé par la commission
européenne qu'il perdrait les fonds
européens qui auraient une procédure
juridique
pour ce viticulteurs et producteurs de
maïs le projet ne mette en danger aucune
espèce animale unique
il assure même que la zone humide
pourrait se déplacer autour du site
pour lui la région a besoin d'eau pour
survivre pas question de renoncer aux
barrages il ya aussi quand même à
regarder la vie sociale de cette vallée
la vie de d'une zone qui va arrêter de
péricliter et qui peut se redynamise
redynamiser on a des villes qui sont pas
très loin il ya que d'un côté montauban
de l'autre qui ont besoin qui
recherchent des circuits courts qui
recherchent des des productions
agricoles localement face à la pression
le projet initial a été remanié il ya
quelques semaines des experts mandatés
par le ministère de l'écologie prône un
barrage de taille réduite avec un
réservoir deux fois plus petit pas de
quoi satisfaire les agriculteurs un
volume qui est très réduit donc on ne
sait pas du tout sur l'avenir n'anticipe
pas du tout sur les besoins qui peuvent
exister on assure un projet qui va
mettre deux trois ans de plus il ne va
pas réduire réduire au résoudre les
problèmes de contentieux et contentieux
européen les résultats new man mais il
faut quand même donner des réponses sur
le
le projet mme progemes projet début mars
les élus du tarn doit voter pour ou
contre ce nouveau projet de barrage mais
avant au conseil général on dit attendre
une décision claire de l'état d'autant
que depuis la mise en demeure de
bruxelles
les fonds européen agricole prévue pour
financer une partie du projet sont
suspendus on est dans une situation un
petit peu complexe où on a aujourd'hui
un projet qui est toujours autorisé les
arrêter les trois arrêtés préfectoraux
sont toujours en vigueur
s'il n'y avait pas une opposition
présentes sur le site
les travaux pour edu continuer et on
attend de la part de l'état suite à la
production de l' expertise ministériel
qu'il puisse prendre les dispositions
nous permettant à nous de pouvoir
s'engager dans un nouveau projet le
ministère s'est engagé à ce que le
projet modifié respecte les critères
européens
mais la france n'est pas à l'abri d'un
nouveau contentieux avec bruxelles
car la nouvelle version du projet de
barrage est toujours situé sur une
partie de la zone humide de sivens
pour l'instant la situation est toujours
quelque peu bloqué sur la zone humide du
testait et sur le projet de barrage de
sylvain c'est pour en parler je reçois
monsieur josé bové comment allez vous ça
va pas mal et monsieur michel dantin
bonjour michel dantin vous êtes député
européen membre du groupe ppe parti
conservateur
ma première question s'adresse à vous
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on arrête le projet
l'a vu le capharnaüm s'y retrouve
absolument pas qu'est ce qu'on fait on
arrête toujours postés sur la table
parce qu'on est dans un schéma
aujourd'hui très classique d'une
contestation de projets alors après on
voit souvent le poids la queue après on
cherche les poux là où on peut les
trouver mais je crois que ce qui est le
reflet de ce combat c'est le combat en
fait entre deux choix de société on veut
de modèle de ce que j'ai compris on est
effectivement dans une démarche qui est
porté par le conseil général qui vise à
la fois à donner de l'eau à
l'agriculture et à augmenter les débits
de la rivière en aval pour permettre de
la poursuite d'un certain nombre de
projets de stations d'épuration et
d'industrie sans avoir à remettre en
cause les normes appliquées à ces
stations d'épuration et à ses industries
josé bové vous vous êtes élus de ce
territoire
quand vous voyez un petit peu la manière
dont la situation s'est cristallisé
autour de cette question de barrage oui
non peut-être est-ce qu'il faut faire un
plus petit barrage ou pas etc
est ce que il faut pour vous tout
arrêter ou est-ce qu'il ya peut-être une
solution qu'on peut trouver sur un
compromis entre les pro et les anti
je crois qu'il faut dissocier en ligne
deux choses les buzz juin pour
l'agriculture et dans quelle agriculture
et la question de leur tenue et qu'elle
retenue donc aujourd'hui il faut
repartir de la réalité du moment il ya
beaucoup de lacs collinaires qui sont
des lacs soit des pentes qui permettent
de stocker de l'eau donc ce sont des
réserves privées
aujourd'hui elles ne sont pas utilisés
les jade est retenu en groupe il ya plus
d'un million de mètres cubes de retenue
elles ne sont pas utilisés en entier la
carde ont d'ores et déjà ce qui est
prévu pour les années à venir
c'est qu'ils aient une mutualisation et
qu'on prélève sur ce qui n'est pas
utilisé ce premier élément
deuxième élément si on doit construire
des nouvelles routes du non est ce qu'on
a besoin pour quelle forme d'agriculture
ça c'est un débat local pour consoler
avec les agriculteurs et les gens
concernés
il faut dire juste pour pour être clair
qu' il ya beaucoup de cultures de maïs
non clairement via le service grandes
cultures en plein sur des terres assez
lourde assez compact hante
mais il ya beaucoup de pentes laval est
assez petit donc les besoins en eau sont
plutôt sur les hauteurs et - vraiment
sur le fond de la vallée
quel type de projet il ya aujourd'hui
sur la table deux propositions on recule
le barrage et on le fait un peu moins
haut mais on reste quand même dans les
terres humides donc ça va reculer le
problème et les conflits qui a avec
l'union européenne sur les questions
environnementales ne seront pas réglés
l'autre projet c'est de faire
éventuellement trois ou quatre heures
retenue d'eau en aval sur des affluents
de ce petit et rivières donc on en est
là quel va être le choix fait par le
conseil général
c'est ce qui va déterminer entre les
deux positions et ce qui permettra aussi
de débloquer problème mais je voudrais
revenir sur un sujet qui est pas abordé
la pour l'instant c'est que on a déjà un
très mauvais exemple dans le département
du tarn qui est le barrage de fou rogge
qui a été construit qui avait été initié
en 90 1997 qui a été contredit contestée
et que le tribunal administratif a dit
qu'il était illégal et qu'il fallait
l'arrêter
or ce barrage est là il fuit il est mal
foutu mais il ya un adage du droit
administratif qui dit que ouvrages
publics mal construits ne se démolit pas
et donc on est dans cette situation
invraisemblable ou à 30 km 46 sinon il
ya une retenue qui a été déclarée
illégale par le tribunal administratif à
l'issue de l'échec qui ne sera jamais
démoli et c'est ce qui explique que à
6,20 la forme de ras-le-bol en fait
des opposants et une occupation du
terrain il ya de toute façon la question
de la procédure d'infraction du
questionnement en fait de la commission
européenne vis-à-vis de la france qui
est lancée aujourd'hui on se rend compte
que la france ne respecte toujours pas
la directive cadre sur l'eau qui date de
2000 comment est-ce que vous expliquer
ce retard votre jugement et me paraît
être un peu rapide d'accords ballon et
ce n'est des mois
la commission européenne a rendu public
en novembre 2013
une évaluation de l'application de la
bce dont la directive cadre sur l'eau
dans l'ensemble des pays européens
donc la france est plutôt dans les pays
qui sont bonnes et les dans les bons
élèves notamment parce qu'au niveau du
classement des masses d'eau et des
objectifs qu'on allait au mac do on est
plus ambitieux que la moyenne des pays
européens d'accord et on a la chance
d'avoir le système de gestion par grand
bassin qui n'existent encore pas dans
les autres pays européens
je devais revenir à l'instant sur la
procédure d'infraction dont il va ou pas
démarré après les réponses donc de paris
question claire quand est ce qu'on sera
en fête qu'est ce qu'il va se passer là
en gros du sinaï dans le train sera
d'ici l'automne d'ici l'otage que bah
oui mais à partir du moment où la
première phase de questionnement est
lancé il ya un an qui peut s'écouler
break au maximum on saura au moins de 9
ans quelle est la position de la
commission européenne
donc là aujourd'hui la france a à ma
connaissance répondu on ne connaît pas
le le texte qui a été
les éléments de la réponse n'a été
apportée maintenant la commission peut
reposer des questions nouvelles ou sur
la réponse qui a été apportée est là
jusqu'au mois de novembre pour prendre
sa décision
et par exemple elle peut typiquement ben
lancer une procédure d'infraction et
interdire à la france de mettre en place
donc ce barrage sur une zone humide ne
l'intéressé pas comme ça que ça se passe
alors ce qui est intéressant moi je
crois que c'est parce que souvent on
critique beaucoup l'europe
ouais mais là quand même ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'as une députée
qui était donc ma collègue au parlement
ce qui est de ma région et donc qui est
élu avec moi en 2009 c'est elle qui a
posé les questions écrites au pas à la
commission au ps en demandant à la
commission de lui répondre et c'est ce
qui a enclenché cette procédure c'est
quand même intéressant c'est que au
niveau de l'europe un citoyen comme un
député peut poser une question et il ya
une suite c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle sur la vision qu'on peut avoir
souvent dit l'europe c'est loin là le
roi en l'occurrence me répondre comme il
existe à la commune au parlement
européen et c'est important de le savoir
une commission des pétitions et qui
permet aux gens de saisir en cas
d'infraction à la législation européenne
michel dantin vous disais que c'était
pas aussi simple qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire par là que en gros c'est pas
parce que on a répondu de manière
favorable ou pas que comme son lavoir
était de l'agencé du la procédure
si elle est transférée et transférer la
cour européenne il ya encore là des
phases de questions réponses dans la
procédure et la commission européenne ne
dispose pas de la capacité s'est fait
bloquer dans les vergers
soyons clairs ce qui veut dire
concrètement on peut être sûr une
procédure longue mais que c'est quand
même intéressant c'est à dire que si une
décision
c'est mieux de saisir la commission
européenne en amont d'un projet plutôt
que d'être obligé de constater que le
projet est une catastrophe et qu' aucun
cas leur déroute stade
voilà donc mais soyons clairs donc ça
veut dire que là en attendant que la
commission statué que la cour européenne
de justice soit saisie ou pas il ne se
passe rien le projet est arrêté tout est
en stand by et dépend de la volonté du
maître d'ouvragé d'accord au jour là ça
dépend du conseil général du tarn ce qui
est clair c'est que la ministre
l'environnement avis le projet ne se
fera pas tel qu'il était prévu qu'un
c'est le premier élément au moins
certain pour autant la déclaration
d'utilité publique n'a pas été n'a pas
été annulé donc là pour l'instant on en
est là rue d'ailleurs dire que la prise
de position de la ministre est une
déclaration d'une déclaration un acte
jury le préfet peut prendre l'acte
juridique ou le conseil bien conseil
général prépare tout si c'est à lui dès
lors il est donc normalement le 9 mars
ils sont bien ou le 8 je sais plus
exactement va très bien peu de
conséquences elle va rendre doit rendre
un avis sur les deux possibilités soit
un barrage plus petit est un peu en
arrière mais toujours en zone humide en
soir dé plusieurs types de barrages sur
des affluents
c'est la décision que doit prendre le
conseil général on attend de voir qu'est
ce qui va se passer
pour l'instant il ya des discussions ça
c'est positif c'est que depuis
malheureusement le décès de rémy fraises
tout le monde s'est mis autour de la
table ce qui n'avait pas été le cas ce
qui n'avait pas été là moi j'avais
demandé tout à fait fin août début
septembre
qu'on ait des réunions de concertation
pour que les acteurs puissent se
retrouve au talent vaz a pas eu lieu
il faut maintenant que la pression
descendent et j'espère que la décision
ira dans le bon sens
ben écoute et on verra on suivra le
dossier merci messieurs d'avoir rester
avec nous pour nous expliquer un petit
peu leurs dossiers extrêmement complexes
nous on se retrouve le mois prochain car
le parlement ne siège pas la semaine
prochaine
ciao et bonne suite de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires
moi